PRESIDENT TRUMP REACTING TO THE
DOJ REVIEW IN THE START OF THE
RUSSIA PROBLEM.
IT'S A CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION.
IT GIVES U.S. ATTORNEY JOHN
DURHAM THE POWER TO SUBPOENA
WITNESSES AND EMPANEL GRAND JURY
AND FILE CHARGES.
DURHAM'S INVESTIGATION HAS
EXPANDED BECAUSE OF NEW
EVIDENCE.
HE'S VERY INTERESTED IN TALKING
TO FORMER OBAMA INTELLIGENCE
OFFICIALS JOHN BRENNAN AND JAMES
CLAPPER.
THE PRESIDENT WEIGHED IN
EARLIER.
>> LOOKS LIKE IT'S BECOMING
SERIOUS FROM WHAT I'M HEARING.
INVESTIGATE THE INVESTIGATORS.
WHETHER IT'S STRZOK AND PAGE,
WHETHER IT'S SLAPPER AND WHETHER
IT'S COMEY AND ALL OF THESE
PEOPLE, BECAUSE TERRIBLE THINGS
WENT ON FOR OUR COUNTRY.
AND WE HAVE A GREAT ATTORNEY
GENERAL, HIGHLY PRESTIGIOUS MAN,
A VERY HONORABLE MAN AND THEY'VE
BEEN LOOKING AT IT FOR A LONG
TIME.
I CAN'T TELL YOU WHAT IS
HAPPENING.
I WILL TELL YOU THIS.
I THINK YOU'LL SEE A LOT OF
REALLY BAD THINGS.
>> Dana: GERALDO, IT'S A
SIGNIFICANT DEVELOPMENT.
THE PRESIDENT IS GIVING THESE
HINTS THAT HE MIGHT HAVE BEEN
TOLD WHAT'S GOING ON.
>> Geraldo: THAT IS A
PROBABILITY.
THE SUBSTANCE OF THE ANSWER IS
THAT THERE'S SOME NIGHT SWEAT
EPIDEMICS GOING ON IN WASHINGTON
RIGHT NOW.
PEOPLE THAT HAVE BEEN PRESSING
THIS FALSE NARRATIVE FOR OVER
TWO YEARS, THE WHOLE RUSSIA
HOAX.
AT SOME POINT THEY HAD TO KNOW
THERE WAS NO THERE THERE BUT
THEY CARRIED ON.
ISSUING ALL OF THESE SUBPOENAS,
ALL OF THESE PERJURY TRAPS,
WEARING HIDDEN MICROPHONES INTO
MEETINGS WITH THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES AND HIS
STAFFERS.
CREATING A CLIMATE OF TERROR IN
THE WHITE HOUSE.
ALL OF THIS FALSE, THE COLLUSION
NARRATIVE, THE HOAX FOR OVER TWO
YEARS AND $45 MILLION WE WERE
LED DOWN THIS PATH.
YOU KNOW, RUSSIA, RUSSIA,
RUSSIA.
IT BECAME A BAD JOKE HOW THE
PRESIDENT MAINTAINS HIS SANITY
THROUGHOUT THIS ORDEAL IS A
GREAT MYSTERY.
I THINK THAT THE PEOPLE THAT
ENGINEERED THIS, THE PEOPLE THAT
CRAFTED THIS HOAX, THE PEOPLE
THAT DREW THE COUNTRY DOWN
THIS -- INTO OZ WILL AT SOME
POINT HAVE TO PAY THE PIPER.
I HAVE NO DOUBT.
>> Dana: WAIT.
DID SOMEONE WEAR A WIRE INSIDE
THE OVAL OFFICE?
>> Geraldo: ROD ROSENSTEIN SAID
IT WAS A JOKE.
>> Dana: WE'RE NOT SAYING THAT
SOMEBODY WORE A WIRE --
>> Geraldo: HOW DID THEY GET --
>> Dana: I DON'T KNOW.
I HAVE NEVER HEARD THAT SOMEBODY
WORE A WIRE IN THE OVAL OFFICE.
>> Geraldo: I STAND LITERALLY
CORRECTED BUT MY POINT IS
WELL-MADE.
>> Dana: INDEED.
>> Greg: THEY ENTRAPPED PEOPLE.
THEY DID EVERYTHING.
>> Dana: ROD ROSENSTEIN WAS
JOKING WHEN HE SAID THAT.
>> THAT'S HOW HE GET HIS RUFFLES
TOGETHER.
HOW ABOUT THE THREE OF GET
MARRIED BUT I'M NOT.
ROD ROSENSTEIN WAS DOING THAT,
BUT NOW IT'S VERY INTERESTING
BECAUSE I DON'T THINK HE WAS
TRYING TO ENGAGE IN ANY SORT OF
NEW MARITAL CONCOCTION.
WHAT I AM SAYING IS THERE WERE
FORCES WORKING AGAINST THE
PRESIDENT AND IT'S NOW LOOKING
AS THOUGH SOME OF THESE THINGS
AT ONE POINT IN OUR VERY RECENT
PATH WE WOULD CALL CONSPIRACY
THEORIES ARE BEARING OUT IN A
WAY THAT IT'S HAPPENING SO
QUICKLY WITH SUCH DEPTH AND
BREADTH.
IT'S HARD TO WRAP YOUR HEAD
AROUND.
YOU UNDERSTAND THE FORCEFULNESS
WITH WHICH THE PRESIDENT DEFENDS
HIMSELF BECAUSE HE FEELS LIKE HE
WAS UNFAIRLY PAINTED INTO A
CORNER.
SOMEONE REALLY WENT AFTER HIM.
I APPRECIATE THE TENACITY WITH
WHICH GERALDO DEFENDS HIM.
I FEEL LIKE I'M NEXT TO JESSE.
>> Dana: ROD ROSENSTEIN IS PART
OF THE INVESTIGATION.
THEY WANT TO TALK TO CLAPPER AND
BRENNAN FROM THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION.
>> Greg: DO YOU MIND IF I BASH
THE MEDIA?
I DON'T DO IT VERY OFTEN.
>> Dana: FOR A CHANGE.
>> Greg: I'M GOING TO TAKE A
BREAK.
OKAY.
I LOVE HOW THE MEDIA IS SAYING,
THIS INVESTIGATION TO THE
RUSSIAN PROBE IS JUST ANOTHER
CONSPIRACY THEORY.
THEY MOCK THE REPUBLICANS FOR
THIS CONSPIRACY THEORY.
IT'S LIKE THE REAL HOUSE WIVES
OF NEW JERSEY CALLING YOU
TRASHY.
THEY PICK THEORIES MORE THAN
MIKE PUSHES PILLOWS.
THEY KNOW THEY CAN'T WIN AN
ELECTION SO THEY'RE LIKE THE
STUPID KID THAT IS TERRIFIED OF
FAILING A FINAL.
SO WHAT DOES HE DO?
HE CALLS IN A BOMB THREAT.
THIS IS THEIR BOMB THREAT.
THEIR WAY OF NOT FACING THE
MUSIC.
GOOD NEWS HERE, I THINK.
I THINK THE TIDE IS TURNING
AGAINST THE DEMOCRATS BECAUSE
THE PROCESS IS SO OUT OF
PROPORTION TO THE INFRACTION.
THERE'S SO MUCH EFFORT TO
PRODUCE SO LITTLE.
REMINDS ME OF THE OSCARS.
STARTS OUT INTERESTING.
LIKE YOU WATCH THE OSCARS THE
FIRST HALF AN HOUR IS GREAT.
WHEN IT'S OVER, WHEN THE OSCARS
ARE OVER, YOU ONLY REMEMBER ONE
THING.
HOW IT WENT ON TOO LONG, HOW
BLOATED AND GROW -- GROTESQUE IT
WAS.
THE LONGER IT GOES ON, THE MORE
LIKELY THE AMERICAN PUBLIC WILL
DETEST IT.
YOU TREAT IT LIKE THE OSCARS,
GET IT OVER.
>> Dana: AND GO TO COMMERCIAL
BREAK.
NOT YET.
>> THE DEMS HAVE A PROBLEM.
THEY'RE TEEING UP -- THE DOJ HAS
LOST THEIR INDEPENDENCE.
THEY'RE SAYING THIS IS POLITICAL
REVENGE.
AND WHEN I LOOK AT IT, THEY'RE
AGAINST THE GOOD OLD BOY SYSTEM.
I DON'T MEAN TO BASH GOVERNMENT
WORKERS.
JONATHAN DURHAM IS NOT ONE OF
THOSE GUYS.
DURHAM IS A GUY THAT HAS
INVESTIGATED THEM BEFORE.
INVESTIGATED THE CIA BEFORE.
THIS IS A GUY THAT WAS GOOD
ENOUGH FOR HOLDER, GOOD ENOUGH
FOR TRUMP AS WELL.
A GUY THAT HAS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT.
BUT HAS STAKED HIS CAREER AFTER
GOING AFTER CORRUPTION.
>> Dana: AND ON THE CIA, HE
DECLINED --
>> AND THE C.I.A. HAS LAWYERED
UP.
>> Dana: YEAH.
THE PREVIOUS ADMINISTRATION
FOUND NO CRIMINAL WRONG DOING.
WE HAVE SOMETHING ELSE.
A BATTLE OVER IMPEACHMENT IS
STILL RAGING.
REPUBLICANS ARE DEMANDING THAT
THE WHISTLE-BLOWER TESTIFY.
NOW DEMOCRATS ARE REPORTEDLY
CLAIM THAT HEARING FROM THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER IS NO LONGER
NECESSARY.
COMES AS THE LEFT AND THE MEDIA
CONTINUE TO MOCK AND ATTACK THE
GOP AFTER THEY STORMED THE
CLOSED-DOOR HEARING THIS WEEK.
>> THIS LOOKED LIKE A KLAN GROUP
OUTSIDE OF A JAIL TRYING TO GET
THE SHERIFF TO LET THEM IN SO
THEY CAN DELIVER THEIR OWN
JUSTICE AGAINST SOMEBODY INSIDE.
IT'S NOT A GOOD LOOK FOR OUR
DEMOCRACY OR FOR THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY.
IAOC IS JOINING IN, CALLING IT A
LITTLE FLASH MOB OR ENTITLEMENT
OF PRIVILEGE.
GREG, THEY DID A STUNT, TRYING
TO MAKE A POINT.
THEY WON THE NEWS CYCLE FOR THE
DAY.
DID IT LOOK LIKE THE KLAN?
>> Greg: HOW CAN IT BE A KLAN IF
THERE'S NO DEMOCRATS?
IT'S ALL REPUBLICANS.
I SEEM TO REMEMBER THE KLAN WAS
MADE UP OF DEMOCRATS.
WHAT KILLS ME --
>> THIS WAS RACIST.
THIS WAS A RACIST -- THAT MAN
WAS A RACIST COMMENT.
>> Greg: IT IS.
I AGREED.
WHAT I FIND INTERESTING GERALDO
AND -- WHEN FACED WITH REAL
MOBS, CHASING PEOPLE OUT OF
RESTAURANTS, HITTING TRUMP
SUPPORTERS, IF YOU CALLED THEM
THE MOB, THE MEDIA CALLED YOU
RACIST.
YOU WEREN'T SUPPOSED TO USE THE
M WORD.
THAT WAS TWO MONTHS AGO.
NOW GUYS AND WOMEN, POLITICIANS,
LAWMAKERS GO TO A MEETING AND
THEY CALL IT A MOP OF WHITE
PEOPLE.
THE KLAN.
SO YOU'RE RIGHT.
I AGREE WITH YOU.
YOU AGREE WITH ME.
LET'S GET A DRINK.
>> Geraldo: REPUBLICANS SHOULD
BE MORE DIVERSE.
YOU GET WHAT THE POINT IS.
THE POINT IS THERE'S A LOT OF
REPUBLICANS THAT FEEL THIS
PROCESS IS GROTESQUELY UNFAIR.
YOU KNOW, I -- THEY SAY IT'S
ABOUT PROCESS.
IT IS ABOUT PROCESS.
DUE PROCESS.
THE PRESIDENT GETS DUE PROCESS.
YOU CAN'T DO IT IN PRIVATE.
YOU DIDN'T DO IT IN PRIVATE IN
98 OR IN 74 AND THEY CAN'T DO IT
IN PRIVATE NOW.
I SAY THE PRESIDENT SHOULD DO
NOTHING TO COOPERATE UNLESS AND
UNTIL THEY OPEN THE HEARINGS.
>> Greg: YOU SHOULD BE HIS
LATER.
>> Geraldo: I FEEL STRONGLY
ABOUT THIS.
TO KENNEDY'S POINT THAT I SOUND
LIKE JESSE WATERS, WE SHOULD ALL
BE OFFENDED THAT WE SANG THIS
RUSSIA DANCE FOR 2 1/2 YEARS AND
SPENT THIS MONEY FOR NOTHING.
WHAT?
THE STEELE DOSSIER?
GOLDEN CHAIR?
WHAT DID THEY BASE THIS ON IN.
>> Dana: OH, BOY.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT.
>> Greg: WHAT'S THAT?
>> Dana: LIKE THE GOLDEN CORRAL.
IT'S A WONDERFUL BUFFET.
MY SISTER LOVES THAT RESTAURANT
SO MUCH.
>> SO DOES ANY GRANDMOTHER.
>> Dana: THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE
PUBLIC HEARINGS IN NOVEMBER.
>> THIS IS A TIME FOR AMERICANS
AND LAWMAKERS TO REEVALUATE
THEIR PAST DECISIONS.
EVERYBODY LOVED THE FISA COURT
FOR SO LONG.
REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS
RALLIED AROUND FOR THE FISA
COURT AND LIBERTARIANS SAID
DON'T TRUST IT.
>> Dana: YES.
>> ME AND YOU DISAGREE ON THAT.
THERE'S NO DUE PROCESS.
SO NOW WE HAVE INSTANCES WHERE
AMERICANS ARE SPIED ON AND A
SHAM INVESTIGATION AND THEY SAY
AT LEAST WE GO A WARRANT FROM A
FISA COURT.
>> Dana: AND MICHAEL HOROWITZ,
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL, SAYS IT'S
WITHIN THE NEXT COUPLE WEEKS OR
SO THAT WE'LL HAVE HIS REPORT
THAT FOCUSES ONLY ON THE FBI'S
ROLE.
>> BUT NOW IT'S VERY
INTERESTING.
THERE'S REPUBLICANS THAT ARE
CONVENIENTLY TALKING ABOUT
THINGS LIKE THE DEEP STATE AND
TALKING ABOUT THE SURVEILLANCE
APPARATUS IN A WAY THAT THEY'RE
OFFENDED BY BUT THEY ARE THE
ONED THAT ALLOWED THE STATE TO
GET THIS BLOATED.
AND THEY REALIZE PEOPLE IN
POWER, ALL YOU HAVE TO DO IS SET
A COUPLE OF TRAPS IN SECRET --
THIS IS OPAQUE.
WE HAVE NO IDEA HOW THIS COURT
WORKS.
WE REALLY DON'T KNOW HOW THE
APPLICATION PROCESS WORKS.
WHAT KIND OF OVERSIGHT THEY HAVE
ONCE AN APPLICATION IS OKAYED
AND YOU CAN --
>> Dana: MAYBE THEY'LL CHANGE
POLICIES --
>> LIBERTARIANS HAVE BEEN
BEGGING TO DO THAT FOR YEARS.
>> Dana: WE DON'T KNOW WHAT THE
RESULTS ARE.
MAYBE THERE WAS A PROBLEM WITH
THIS PARTICULAR ONE.
I DON'T THINK THAT MEANS THAT
THE ENTIRE FISA COURT PROCESS OF
WHICH HAS BEEN VERY USEFUL IN
TERMS OF PROTECTING NATIONAL
SECURITY SHOULD BE THROWN OUT.
>> OPEN IT UP --
>> AND WHERE IS THE FISA JUDGE?
>> Geraldo: IF THE JUDGE WAS
LIED TO --
>> BRING THEM BACK IN.
>> Geraldo: THAT'S WHAT THE
INVESTIGATION BY THE I.G. WILL
UNCOVER.
I BET THEY DID WIRETAP THE TRUMP
TOWER.
I BET ALL OF THE PARANOIA WILL
COME TRUE.
>> Greg: HOW CONVENIENT IS IT
NOW TO NEED THE WHISTLE-BLOWER
ANYMORE?
THE WHISTLE-BLOWER SHOWS UP,
BLOWS HIS WHISTLE.
SO WHAT THEY NEED IS THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER TO FIND THE
CRIME.
NOW THEY HAVE THE CRIME, THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER CAN LEAVE.
>> Dana: HE WAS A FISA JUDGE.
>> Greg: THAT'S WHO IT IS.